- Oh my gosh.
I have to say too, God,
you walked in today and I
just saw what you're wearing
when we walked in and I was like,
and then you walked out
today, like in this.
And I was like, oh my gosh.
You, have you always been into fashion?
- Yes.
- Is it just natural for you?
- Well, no, speaking
of the church, you know
the black church is a fashion child.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I'm first generation
post civil rights movement.
So, you know, I was taught
that the first impression
is what you look like.
So, you must dress up.
I came from the, you dress up in suits.
I wore a suit to school.
I wore a jacket and a tie
to public high school.
- Yeah.
- You know, dress for the job you want,
not the one you have was what
my great Aunt Dorothy told me.
- Yeah.
- So, you know, there were
lots of combinations of that.
And then I've been able to now use
my fashion sense as activism.
- Yeah. I like that.
- [Billy] Yeah.
- To make a political statement as well.
- [Kelly] Yeah. And do you,
I feel like every time I see you, like
on a red carpet, like
literally you are a walking,
fashion but also slash
political statement.
- Yes.
- And there's always something
happening that that's deeper.
And I love that.
- Always dual, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah. And that's on purpose?
- It's always on purpose.
Everything I do is intentional.
- Okay. I love it.
- Everything I do is on purpose.
- Yeah.
- You know, and, and because
I've lived long enough
I've been in this business for 35 years
I've made the decision that what I wanted
to do as an artist,
was to use my art to heal.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- My art, art is healing.
- Because it's so healing for us.
- It's healing
- Yes, You wanna share that.
- And I wanna share that. Yeah.
- Yeah, I just saw those pictures.
I wanna bring up the inspiration,
like your inspiration
with the, with the fashion you've used.
I wanna bring up those
pictures once again.
This, I remember this first one,
I think, were you at
the Oscars right there?
- [Billy}] Yes.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- The Oscars, the Oscars was really where
it's, where it popped off.
There was a Golden Globe before that.
Which was the first time
on a major red carpet.
- Yeah.
- But when the Oscars called, I knew,
you know, this is the
entertainment Super Bowl.
My friend Idina Menzel a few years prior
you know, her name was
said wrong, and I saw
- We, we all saw.
- [Billy] Adele Davine.
- Yeah.
- And then she became a
household name because of that.
And the businessman inside
of me was like, well, what,
when "ABC" called to ask me to
be on the red carpet, I said
well, what is my,
what is my wrong name calling gonna be?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, what is it?
- Yeah, what will be memorable,
but also have a message.
Like I,
- Absolutely.
- when I saw that dress, I was like,
well, hell, I'd wear that.
Like, I, I love, I love that.
- Yes!
- Yeah!
- And my thought was,
you know because I used to
always say when I was in,
at Carnegie Mellon Drama School,
- Yeah.
- We would have Oscar
parties and I would be like,
I'm, I'm not gonna wear that penguin suit.
I'm gonna wear, I'm gonna wear a gown.
I'm gonna wear a gown.
And it's interesting
because words do have power.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Even when you're not conscious of it.
So 30 years later, 25
years later, whatever,
I'm asked to do this thing and I was like,
oh I remember I said I was
gonna wear a gown to the Oscars.
And so I got to Christian Siriano
and I thought, well, if it starts,
- I love him.
- if it's, if the shot starts here
and it looks like just
a traditional tuxedo
and then when you pull
out, it's a full gag.
- [Kelly] I know because,
- It'll change the world!
- Because there's more than just the top.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yes!
- There's more to, to a
person than even one outfit.
I love it.
I'm not, I am not that into fashion.
That's why I love watching it.
'cause I'm, I don't innately go.
I am like the person you hate.
I wear like workout clothes every day.
And I don't work out on them.
(Billy laughs)
It's like, look, they're comfortable.
- Athleisure.
- It seems practical.
I am 100% athleisure.
- And you have two children.
- I know.
- And, and athleisure is cool now.
- I would love to blame
it on the children.
I was this on tour before.
Yeah. I've always with this
person, but I love watching it.
You know, I'm not a
painter, but I love art.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I love, I love all of that.
But I, I have to ask too,
like, have you always had, like
'cause I get so jealous
of such distinct voices.
I feel like I have a good voice,
- You have a distinct voice!
- [Kelly] It's not
distinct. I'm a chameleon.
- That's a lie.
- No, no. I feel like my gift
I feel like my gift is,
I can be a chameleon.
I like going
- You can be, and you
have your own distinction.
- I don't know about that, but
I love, but like your voice
like the certain level of
just like rasp and beauty
to a voice that I'm like,
have you always had that?
Was it ever different? Or did you smoke?
- Yeah. It was diff-, no, no, no.
No, it was different earlier.
- Okay.
- My voice when I was young
was pristine and clear.
- Oh, like a choir boy.
- And really high, but like
Jennifer Hudson as a choir boy.
- Yeah.
- Like I was a high belting soprano,
- Love.
- like belt, belt, belt.
- Yeah.
- And then in 2001, right after 9/11
I got severe acid reflux.
- [Kelly] Ooh.
- And my voice went away for about
three or four years.
- Oh!
- Yeah, it was horrible.
- Oh my God emotionally that,
- It was one of the worst
- I don't even know what I's do.
- times of my life.
It was the worst, one of
the worst times of my life.
And my voice teacher Joan Lader
and my doctors and everybody, you know
really came together and took care of me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And a new voice emerged.
- Yeah.
- And I've leaned into it.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love it.
- And I love my new voice.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And everybody else seems
to love the rasp too.
- Yeah. Because them ears.
(audience cheers)
- His new album is called Black Mona Lisa.
I love the album title.
- Yes!
- Where did that come from?
- Okay. So we were record-,
we were writing the album.
I was doing a lot of writing
with Justin Transer who you know,
- [Kelly] I love, love Justin, yeah.
- who I love.
And the team was all in there
and we're like six months in.
And I don't remember
where the title came from
but it just showed up.
Black Mona Lisa
and like the whole room froze.
- [Kelly] And look at that art.
Oh my God.
- Yeah. The whole room froze.
And I was like, oh my God.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
And then like 20 minutes
later, we had written the song.
- Yeah.
- And what I love about it
and what it means for me
because this album is so personal
and it's the first, it's my fifth album.
And it's the first one where
I've written everything.
- It's all original, right?
- Except one song.
- All original,
It's a pop album.
I've written an all but one song
and everything is from
the depths of my soul.
I have lived a life
and I get to talk about that
life through the original gift.
- Yeah.
- Which is my voice.
And so, you know conceptually,
the Mona Lisa,
is relevant, past, present
- Will be
- And forevermore.
- Yeah. It's classic.
- [Billy] So I'm saying that about myself.
- Yeah.
- I'm claiming that about myself.
You have to speak life into yourself
- Yeah. You have to
know that about yourself
and feel it about yourself if
somebody else is gonna see it.
- [Billy] Correct.
- Yeah.
- So I'm, I'm learning to
speak life into myself.
- which is important.
- Right. Because if you, if
one can't sit in the fullness
of their purpose, then we
don't know how to show up
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Properly.
- Oh wow. I love it.
- You know what I mean?
- Yes, I do. Yes.
- And it's hard because,
you know, we live in a space
where so many people have
opinions about stuff.
And when you know who you are
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you can speak about that power.
Very often you're labeled as arrogant.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Or narcissistic.
- Yeah.
- Right, and that's not the case.
There's a difference.
There's a fine line, but
there is a difference.
And I have in, in the last few years
been able to find that power in my,
in my life, in art, in
work, in everything.
- I had an advice-
Go ahead!
(audience cheers)
I had,
somebody gave me advice a
while, years and years ago.
And I loved it 'cause it was,
it reminded me of something you said
but it was like, take advice
only as advice, not gospel.
- [Billy] Absolutely.
- Because you know, you know your truth.
But it's also great to hear
other people and their ideas.
But at the same time, like,
especially with artists
it's like, you know who
you are deep inside.
Like, and what your purpose is
supposed to be as an artist.
- Right.
- Not to be like somebody else.
So I, I love that as well.
I have to talk about this
because I love these lyrics.
Sometimes I fall into damaging thoughts.
Right, that's a whole
conversation right there.
Like, I don't deserve all the love I got,
but then I take a second just to breathe,
I always come back to me.
What, explain what is that?
It's very powerful.
- As a,
black, queer man,
in this world.
I have been told for years
and the messaging has
been that I don't matter.
We are living in a time right now,
where at the highest levels
of government, churches,
humanity,
folks are dismissing
entire groups of human beings.
- It's like, we're going backwards.
It's, yeah, we're going backwards again.
- And the power has to come from inside.
I, you know, being a gay man,
it's like the, the, the idea
of like acceptance and tolerance.
I don't need your acceptance.
I don't need your tolerance.
I demand your respect for my humanity.
Like I respect everybody else's.
(audience cheers)
- Amen. And then also when
people start talking about
tolerance and acceptance
that's so demeaning to me in
those words because I feel
like, no, no, you should just love them.
You, you can just love
them like who they are.
- Well, it also puts the validation
for yourself in somebody else's hands.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Validate yourself.
- I don't need anybody
else to validate me.
- Yes.
- I am enough. Just as I am.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience claps)
I guess I have two questions here.
Like, how do you fight-,
'cause they're, people are
being attacked like on a
like you said, a government level.
They're trying to pass laws that literally
send us backwards.
And that is fearful for
me as a mama as well.
Not only for me in my everyday life
but as a mom, raising
a boy, raising a girl.
I want them to grow up in an environment.
They can literally be
anything they want to be.
And that is awesome.
- Yeah
- [Kelly] 'cause that is your purpose.
- Yeah.
- How do you, how do you keep the fight
for that while also like
because the LGBTQ+ community
is definitely under attack.
And so how do you, how do you
do that without, 'cause I feel
like people are being like,
oh, they're being, you know
aggressive about it,
or something and you're
fighting for what is just right.
- [Billy] Yeah.
- Like how do you fight
for that in your way?
- Well, first of all,
respond, and don't allow
anybody to police your response.
- Yeah.
- There's a reason why I'm aggressive.
You attack me, and then I'm the problem.
That's called gas lighting.
- Oh, I, I know it well.
- So we're not doing that.
So we're not doing that anymore.
- Yeah, no, we're not.
- But the thing that I move,
the, the the thing that
grounds me is I'm 54 years old.
I came out in 1985.
I lived through the AIDS crisis.
I know,
that love always wins.
I've seen it.
It's a circle of life, right?
(audience claps)
- Yeah.
- So what we have to do,
who are the people in the
positions to make the change
is understand that the
change has already happened.
That's why the pushback is so severe.
- I know, but also,
I don't find it aggressive
to just stand up
for something so simplistic
- [Billy] It's not!
- as just being able to be you.
- [Billy] It's not.
- That's not aggressive for me.
- And that's a silencing
mechanism from the other side.
I see it all the time.
Whether they use the buzz
word of politicization.
Well, yes, of course it's politicized!
You're trying to take my rights away!
- Yeah.
- Yes, it's political!
You're trying to silence me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that is not going
to happen in the arts.
You know, when I,
because I'm a writer too.
- Yeah.
- So another birth buzzword for me is,
oh, it's too preachy.
Somebody needs to be preached to.
- [Kelly] Yeah I was gonna say,
- Because the world is a mess!
- Yeah. We're not killing it.
We're not killing it.
But you know what's so funny? I'm gonna,
- Y'all just want me to shut up.
I'm gonna come right, I'm gonna come-
Well, I understand that well too,
'cause I'm a woman, but like, but, but
- Exactly.
- Yeah. I love that.
But I love that it comes
full circle though.
Like you said, the
preaching wasn't for you.
But I think that preaching
exists in different forms.
- Absolutely.
- And you are very good.
- [Billy] Absolutely.
- At motivating people.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Why not use that purpose,
- Yeah. Why not use that passion?
We could talk for hours.
- Like and we will later.
- [Kelly] And we probably
will after, yeah!
- We will later. This is,
- But let's, let's take
another break though.
Billy's album is called Black Mona Lisa.
He's performing a song off of it later.
You gotta check it out.